you didn't see that coming it's
interesting cuz yes their photos are
always leaked and then there's lots of
conjecture about what those photos mean
certainly there is a very a 5 minute
sequence in civil war around a piece of
technology that that that was laid in
for a very specific reason so to go back
and look at that film we may get a hint
as to a direction
hey everybody its charlie I've been
getting a lot of requests for a
Quicksilver video because we've been
seeing so much stuff happen in the past
specific to Avengers 4 people are just
wondering if they're gonna bring
Quicksilver back for that movie and it
was reported that he was seen on the set
of Avengers 4 out in Atlanta so if
you're finding me for the first time I
am doing a giveaway for the Avengers
infinity war DVD all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on the video the intro that I
cut into this probably gives you an idea
for the direction that I'm thinking
based on what the Russos have said about
the pictures in their classic Avengers
costumes that leaked a while ago he's
like you know there's a very special
scene during civil war that might give
you an idea of what's going on there
I've already done a bunch of videos
about that the Russos also separately
when asked about their ideas on time
travel how do you feel about time travel
movies they're like well you know we we
like those movies when they're done well
and that's about all they said tongue
and she just trying to give the biggest
non-answer that they could because they
don't want to give any spoilers away but
if it wasn't obvious that device that
they're talking about the be AR effing
that Ironman introduces during civil war
that's what they're talking about for
these Avengers pictures by nearly
augmented retro framing or barf god I
got to work on that acronym an extremely
costly method of hijacking the
hippocampus to clear traumatic memories
it doesn't change the fact that they
never made it to the airport
or all the things I did to avoid
processing my grief which is also what I
think is going on with all this
Quicksilver talk because Aaron
taylor-johnson the actor that plays
Quicksilver was seen on the set of
Avengers when they were filming these
types of scenes with door had his long
blonde hair from the first two Avengers
films
so using Point Break Thor as a bit of a
marker for the stuff that they were
probably working on around that time in
the fact that Frank Grillo's crossbones
character was also seen on that same set
it just sounds like they're gonna be
spending a lot of time looking at their
memories revisiting their old major
battles so what does that all have in
common and why would they need to go
back and look at what's happening during
the events of the first Avengers film
the second Avengers film well the big
thing is is that they all involved
Infinity stones and even though these
scenes imply they're just looking into
the past through their memories that
doesn't mean they won't actually
physically time travel into the past
that's still wide open for theory
crafting I don't want to speculate too
much about that yet without more
information but there are actually a
couple important reasons for why they
would go back and visit these moments
you know one to learn about what was
going on the original Avengers movie you
have the mind stone and you have the
space stone at the same time so they can
learn more about what was going on then
then you also have the mind stone again
when they were creating vision during
age of Ultron the other really big
reason why they would want to go back
and revisit these is as a way to
memorialize this era of Marvel movies
like they've had all that 10-year Marvel
anniversary stuff they released before
infinity war think about how far we come
back when we did Iron Man 1 we never
thought this would happen
but we're so happy that it did so you
have everybody you know patting
themselves on the back high-fiving each
other for how awesome it is but they
need some way to memorialize that on
film so what better way to look at the
past then to literally have them look at
the past in the movie and make that a
big part of the plot so that way you can
have these funny moments with cap in his
classic costume you can have ant-man
standing there next to them and you
don't have to bring everybody back right
away
so a lot of this looks like it's
happening is they're trying to plan for
how to bring everyone back because for
the most part they've said the people
that didn't get really big parts during
it
he wore like Captain America he was in
there but he didn't have a whole lot to
do compared to some of the other
characters they'd be much bigger during
Avengers 4 so I don't think that they're
gonna rush to bring all those people
that were turned to ash right back
they're gonna spend most of the movie
trying to figure that out then later
during the big third act climax some
Avenger makes the big sacrifice to wield
the Infinity stones again brings
everyone back then at the end Sebastian
Stan actually said there was a scene
where like all these characters were
on-screen together
he said Michelle Pfeiffer's Janet Van
Dyne was there Michael Douglas's ant-man
was there so it just sounds like
everybody comes back by the very end of
Avengers 4 if they have a really big
group shot moment it's either
celebratory or a memorial service
because someone has sacrificed
themselves and died so that everyone
else could live but just remember that a
lot of the stuff that you've seen from
behind the scenes so far this ba are
effing stuff looks like it happens
relatively early in the film and then
they enact their plant like they look
back get the evidence that they need
form some conclusions then start going
after the gems now this is really where
we get into pure speculation territory
because people have been wondering if
they actually jump back into the past to
grab the gems before
Thanos got them and through that they
revisit old moments in the history of
the MCU so they're like hey remember
that really awesome time that we had
during those first couple of Thor films
well we're just gonna go back in time
and yank the aether from before any of
that happen so we can avoid it falling
into the collectors hands so that Thanos
never gets it without going too deep
into that one of the big reasons for
them to keep ant-man around especially
during these scenes is because of the
quantum realm and what they find out
about it during ant-man of the wasp
mostly that it's an alternate way of
time-traveling and the idea that ant-man
could also probably go into the soul gem
meaning that he could enter the soul
world physically that way although the
way they do that in the comics is a
little bit different if you're big comic
book reader the Infinity Gauntlet
actually addresses that directly where
you have Adam warlock that's trapped
inside the soul gem Doctor Strange
speaks to him on the astral plane so you
have two very powerful Marvel characters
communicating with each other on
different planes of existence so there
are ways that they could accomplish that
with the characters that they have now
Captain Marvel is kind of a rogue right
now Wong could probably commute
with dr. strange while he's inside the
soul world but like I said in other
videos there's the story of the people
that are left alive and that's mostly
what we've been talking about thus far
and all the behind the scenes we've seen
but then there's also the people that
have died and are now stuck inside the
soul gem so I would be blown away if we
do not see any black panther or any dr.
strange in the next movie
it's just Black Panther is too big of a
character to completely leave him out
from 90% of the movie till everybody
comes back at the end or to leave
someone as powerful and knowledgeable as
dr. strange out you just have to
remember what our man's arc is across
all these movies like he's sort of on
this parallel with Thanos so when you're
thinking about the character that's
gonna bring them together and keep them
moving down this path to fixing
everything it's really gonna be Iron Man
but then I think that's also going to
rope in Captain America's arc because
they have to resolve the conflict with
those two characters and usually Captain
America is the person to give you that
call to action Iron Man is the problem
solver but let me know in the comments
what do you think that they're going to
learn when they revisit these memories
from the first and the second Avengers
movies it's not really a big issue right
now but can you not wait to see how they
explained the other Quicksilver from the
x-men universe if that Fox Disney deal
goes through I'll do an update if
there's any really big news about that
but leave all your bonus video requests
in the comments below and I'll name a
new giveaway winner when I post new
Marvel but click here for brand new
infinity war and click here for all my
solo Easter eggs thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]